vice president Kamala Harris getting
mocked and criticized once again after
dishing out another one of her now
notoriously scrambled responses which
her critics have taken to calling a word
salad the vice president was meeting
with the Jamaican prime minister for
example when she blurted this out
for Jamaica one of the issues that has
been presented as an issue that is
economic in the way of its impact has
been the pandemic
So to that end we are announcing today
also that we will assist Jamaica in
covid recovery by assisting in terms of
the recovery efforts in Jamaica that
have been essential to I believe what is
necessary to strengthen not only the the
issue of Public Health but also the
economy
you just have The Yips Remember The Yips
I don't think so I don't actually I
don't even know what the Yips are the
twisties you know like uh
if that's the case you have to ask
yourself how do you become where you get
to be where you are with The Yips you
know have you did you ever have to
diagram sentences when you were in
Middle School you couldn't diagram I
don't remember if you diagram yeah that
would go right out of the class no it
basically ends up looking like the
bottom of the Mississippi but goes in
like 40 different directions it's like
impossible to do
um
all she had to do to be not considered
the worst vice president in history was
nothing
Do no harm that's the role of the vice
president if you can help great but
don't cause any problems don't be
somebody that is going to be basically
lampooned you have to wonder if Saturday
Night Live will do anything with this on
Saturday night right judge you would
have to ask that yeah
um I saw you again last week
think of how many there's probably 30
Vice Presidents in history who are not
remembered for anything and they're
totally fine with that and I'm afraid in
this situation I just don't see how it
gets any better who's worse Greg the
current vice president or Spyro agner
I'm how old do I look how about Aaron
Burr uh Aaron Burr I don't uh you know
of course he killed the Secretary of the
Treasury you know you hold that against
him all the time she would make a
terrible doctor could you imagine the
diagnosis but you know what you know
what you know what Kamala needs she
needs a significant passage of time in
between her gaffs so there are more few
there are more significant passions of
time between her gaps which are
significant given the insignificant
passage of time between them meaning
that I admire her ability to use five
words to make a 50 word sentence
somebody's got to create an algorithm
like a Kamala Harris sentence generator
where you just insert four or five words
and see what you get I could do that all
day some of the Loaves and the fishes
yes the lows
being made the scapegoat for the for the
foibles of the Biden Administration who
cares she needs help and I'm gonna help
her right now
wait wait I'm just saying that you want
the country to help Jamaica to recover
after covet say I'm trying to help
Jamaica recover economically you don't
have to say it with so many words and I
hear I know what's going on
she's not comfortable with herself she's
a prosecutor right she's not a
politician
speak like a prosecutor get to the point
like this prosecutors just nail it they
don't have to sound like a technocratic
diplomat like blinken or like mayor Pete
who speak like a bureaucrat you know you
don't have to talk like that just be
yourself Shoot Straight speak from the
heart but she's getting handed words and
sentences that are gobbledygook from
these young 30 year old master's degrees
in government policy and she's just
reading it and she's trying to be
someone she's not she needs to take a
little hike maybe take a few days off
maybe a vacation lick a toad find
herself and then re-center and come back
a toad you know you can get a little
psychedelic experience oh there you go
that's why I look directly at you you
don't know about the toad licking yeah I
do I am well aware of it and it works
can you show us yes I'll show you later
okay yeah
I don't care if you're a prosecutor or a
politician you're the vice president of
the United States of America to me the
greatest country in the world it's not
her people giving her word salads I
would not let this woman out of wherever
the hell she is unless she could write
down on a piece of paper what she's
going to say she should not be allowed
out Kamala what are you going to say
stop with the and by the way when I saw
that video I said oh this must be an old
one she said she this can't be new it's
new she keeps coming out and
embarrassing herself but she's
embarrassing not only the United States
but every woman who's trying to get
ahead keeper keep her in the West Wing
or wherever the hell you keep the vice
president she embarrassed Jamaica that's
where your father's from of all the
places
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else